وما اعلنته الاذاعه الرسميه الاسرائيليه
ورفض عدد من الجنود جنود الاحتياط على وجه
الخصوص المشاركه في القتال داخل قطاع غزه
ماذا في التفاصيل
نجوى نعم ازدهار وهذا كشف استثنائي في خضم
الحرب بمعنى ان مثل هذه الامور عاده لا
يتحدث عنها الاعلام الاسرائيلي خلال
القتال خلال الحرب ولكن هذا ال اليوم
عندما تم نشر عن هذا الموضوع بان عدد كبير
من جنود الاحتياط قرروا الانسحاب وعدم
الامتثال للخدمه والدخول للقتال الى قطاع
غزه بعد ان تم استدعائهم من اجل المشاركه
في مهام دفاعيه لتشكيل كتيبه تحت مسمى
الحارس وهي كتيبه جديده بدا يعد لها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في اعقاب الحرب على غزه من اجل
الدفاع كما جاء في الاذاعه العبريه عن
بلدات غلاف غزه تحديدا كي لا
يتكرر ما حدث في السابع من اكتوبر
بالاضافه الى حراسه مستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه الا انه وخلال عمليات التدريب
فوجئ الجنود من قوات الاحتياط بانه سيتم
ادخالهم للقتال في داخل قطاع غزه دون ادنى
تدريبات ملائمه لمثل هذه المهام التي وصفت
بانها
بالاساس ما يقال عنها تطهير منازل
الفلسطينيين في داخل غزه من المسلحين اي
عمليات تفتيش من بيت الى بيت والبحث عن
وسائل قتاليه واسلحه بالاضافه بالاضافه
الى عمليات ل رصد والوصول الى فوهات انفاق
وانفاق في داخل قطاع غزه وفي مقابله مع
الاذاعه العبريه ايه سمعتها هذا اليوم كان
يتحدث اثنان من هؤلاء الجنود عن
الكثير من الخلل في التدريبات التي اجريت
لهم بانها تدريبات دفاعيه فقط لا تمت بصله
للمهام القتاليه التي فوجئوا بانهم
سيتولون خلال هذه المهمه ومن من جهه اخرى
عن نواقص كثيره جدا والكثير من المشاكل
التقنيه فيما يتعلق بكميه العتاد والذخائر
احد الجنود قال بانهم كانوا في بعض الا
الاحيان يبحثون عن
الرصاصات المستخدمه كي يستخدمونها مره
اخرى من على الارض لاجراء تدريبات معينه
بالاضافه الى انهم لم يكن بحوزتهم ملابس
واقيه كالدرع واحدهم اشار الى انه في بعض
الاحيان كانوا يبحثون عن الاحذيه العسكريه
التي ينتعله الجنود في الحرب وتحدثوا عن
عدم اداره مناسبه من قبل الق قاد
الميدانيين لمثل هذه المهمات العسكريه
ولمثل هذه التدريبات الاذاعه العبريه ذكرت
موضوع ان مثل هذه الامور ربما يصعب تقبلها
وسماعها في فتره الحرب وعندما قالت
المذيعه خلال هذا هذه المداخله سنسال من
جهات رسميه لماذا نثير مثل هذه الامور في
خضم الحرب اجابها احد الجنود كي لا يموت
منا من الجنود عدد اكبر لذلك انسحبنا من
هذه المهمه و رفضنا الامتثال للخدمه
العسكريه والدخول الى غزه والحديث يدور عن
ما لا يقل من 50% من الكتيبه من الجنود في
هذه الكتيبه ازدهار